alors aujourd'hui on va travailler avec
une petite poudre rejoindre qu'on
appelle les sit in de soya on va
l'utiliser comme en savon comestibles du
savon oui pour faire des bills ok on
fait des mousses exactement donc et
l'émotion nous servir à faire ça
des cocktails d'amour à la mousse de
gingembre et des huîtres à légumes de
cupidon c'est quand déjà la
saint-valentin qu'on le nomme punch qui
ou encore pas qu' une bonne qui au
canada à la veille du carême à varsovie
se baigner est roi jacky mismatch nago
en grève la fête de pâques est la plus
importante de l'année la tresse de pain
brioché touré qui est au coeur des
célébrations c'était très il ya des
plupart des gens maintenant pas
tellement croyante mais on suit nos
traditions le vendredi saint a toujours
été synonyme de privations mais
heureusement pour les gourmands une
gâterie permise et ce même pour les plus
pieux
pour les catholiques c'est la brioche de
pâques moi ça fait des années que je
fais ça au 100 m en 10 sec mais je
comprends que les gens veuillent
vendredi matin là c'est plus un
sacrifice et bibelots prête à
pax envier et qui dit pâques dit
chocolat un bon chocolat quand on casse
avec claque si ça fait
considérer que ce n'est pas un bon choix
à une certaine époque quand on fait l
action de grâce en famille on mettait
sur la table non pas une aide mais une
oie oh la la la la qu'est les blés noirs
quand tu prends moi ma famille et mes
cinq enfants c'est fascinant c'est
quatre policiers au
halloween elle est la reine des
décorations mais au lendemain de la fac
des bonbons la reine se retrouvent bien
souvent le dépotoir antique et ses deux
fils pour ce qu'il est une des grandes
difficultés avec 11 tirs instruisent
ciné-clap très difficile à pénétrer ce
qu'on fait c'est qu'on l'aimé laser et
on va l'acheter volontairement partage
non je sais pas qui vous passez y met en
amazone bonne c'est le moment de vous
présenter le bon achat faire cette
semaine mais d'abord nous produit
vedette relais dont bon pourquoi les
dons bon
niveau selon lwin on se casse pas la
tête avec les warrants d'optionnel ça
continue sur le sucre va se cristalliser
tout en tombant pour créer ce qu'on
appelle des cheveux d'ange
alors imaginez je suis un ange la barbe
à papa on a notre
île pas été d'halloween
commence
le 24 septembre ce sera le début du
ramadan à ce moment là les musulmans
pratiquants doivent jeûner à partir du
lever jusqu'au coucher du soleil malak
et sa mère passeront la journée à
cuisiner sans boire ni manger avant le
coucher du soleil mais le soir s'ils
festa top comme le travail ont du temps
des fêtes mais pendant 30 jours fin
d'année deux modèles en vraies cueillies
les gens des différentes cultures et
différentes même religion aussi pour
partager toutes les beautés et un sens à
partir de l'épiphanie le 6 janvier on
peut fêter les rois mages jusqu'au mardi
gras avec la traditionnelle galette des
rois où se cache en fait
j'ai l'impression
de faire un couronnement il ya un rêve
que j'ai trop mal à la cour du roi louis
xiv la reine du jour on dirait que c'est
organise avec le gars des vues oh non
j'ai déjà mon genou
va leur consacrer
qui dit fête dit gâteau et pour marquer
le coup en effet pas et un boa passé
salue sa tête
[Musique]
merci demande